a gente falar de igualdade de
oportunidades é sempre muito difícil
porque é complexo mas também é muito
necessário nos tempos atuais e para
poder falar sobre igualdade de
oportunidades
eu gostaria de começar com a ajuda de
vocês prestando uma homenagem a uma
grande guerreira lutadora que essa
semana foi assassinada brutalmente no
rio de janeiro e que era uma mulher
preta obre lésbica que estava dando a
cara a tapa e sim lutar pela
transformação social
mariele franco deve permanecer viva
entre nós o espírito de luta da marielly
deve permanecer entre nós
então eu gostaria de começar essa
palestra pedindo um minuto de silêncio
para marielly franco
[Música]
mariele franco presente
[Aplausos]
fêmeas vou falar uma coisa legal
quero começar bem positiva e esse mês de
março eu completo um ano que eu defendi
minha tese de doutorado
eu fiz minha defesa na faculdade de
educação da unicamp que hoje é uma das
melhores universidades do mundo
se não me engano é melhor da américa
latina foram 16 anos fazendo carreira
acadêmica todos financiados com dinheiro
público em universidade pública para que
eu conseguisse defender minha tese no
ano de 2017 mas vou contar pra vocês um
segredo na verdade não é segredo que eu
adoro contar essa história desde os meus
nove anos
eu sabia que eu queria ser estudiosos
que eu queria ser pesquisadora muito
precoce sim mas eu tenho uma lembrança
muito forte de um período da minha vida
e meu irmão a gente ficava sozinha em
casa no contraturno da escola como toda
a família de pobre não tinha ninguém
para tomar conta das crianças então
minha mãe ia trabalhar e deixava as
coisas arrumadas café da manhã em tudo
mais não pôde entrar na conta aquelas
coisas não pode entrar na cozinha se
alguém me chamar fala que estou tomando
banho nunca diga que vocês estão
sozinhos nem sempre essas orientações e
uma das coisas que a gente tinha que
fazer sozinho a estudar porque minha mãe
meu pai trabalhava fora e não tinha
tempo de estar com a gente e eu lembro
que era uma coisa extremamente prazerosa
pra mim eu lembro exatamente da situação
de um dia eu estava estudando para uma
prova e aí eu abrir há como a gente não
tinha mesmo então abrir os cômodos onde
guardava as roupas e colocava os livros
ele estudava e eu lembro de um dia que
estava estudando para uma prova que eu
não me engano era de português eu tentei
cavar na memória essa semana para ver se
era isso mesmo mas enfim
e me lembro da sensação de de sentir que
estava mudando enquanto eu aprendia
depois de alguns minutos estudando falo
nossa eu sei fazer isso agora isso é
tático e aí aquelas coisas de criança
nessa data é boneca tem uns querem ser
bombeiro tal e aí eu fiquei pensando
nossa será que alguém pagaria para fazer
isso a vida inteira e foi e foi meio que
um é assim uma luz naquele momento que
óbvio naquele momento não sabia o que
era ser uma adutora é na minha família é
enorme na época eu acho que apenas uma
pessoa tinha conseguido fazer um curso
universitário mas aquilo apareceu na
minha cabeça naquela hora e durante a
minha vida foi me perseguindo e então eu
consegui fazer uma carreira acadêmica é
fazer um doutorado sanduíche enfim hoje
eu sou uma professora pesquisadora
formada e gostaria realmente de passar a
vida fazendo isso aí nessa hora vocês
devem estar claramente nossa que bacana
nessa mulher e negra ela é é nordestina
essa mulher é mulher ela faz parte de
uma minoria como foi que ela conseguiu
aos nove anos pensar em uma meta e
atingir essa meta com tanta
assertividade
aí eu deveria fazer o que desenvolver
aqui né contar pra vocês nas fórmulas
mentais das coisas que eu elaborei para
chegar até a minha meta né
a fórmula aquela fórmula secreta das
pessoas que se dedicam
mas não é isso que eu vou fazer eu não
vou fazer isso
pelo seguinte motivo você creditar o seu
sucesso apenas ao seu esforço individual
é você reproduzir uma lógica classista e
racista e eu vou dizer pra vocês porque
no brasil hoje apenas 14% da população
consegue concluir o ensino superior
eu faço parte desse 14% que quem é quem
tem graduação ou tá fazendo o autor ou
já concluiu ao olha que o povo estudioso
quem é que tem mestrado
quem tem doutorado ou está cursando
quem é preto e tem doutorado aqui foi a
batata que irmão
aham mas nós estamos aqui diante de uma
minoria eu irmão ali somos uma minoria
absoluta é essa minoria ela se reflete
também nos números que a gente vê nas
pesquisas como eu disse 14% da população
em geral têm ensino superior que a gente
está numa média muito maior no público
apenas 0,5 por cento da população tem
doutorado
só que eu não tenho nem se os números
relacionados à raça porque
historicamente no brasil raça nunca foi
uma questão como se nunca se a gente não
tivesse racismo então eu falando esse
número aqui como número geral e agora
vocês vejam a lógica do que eu vou
chamar aqui de meritocracia que a
história do que quem quer consegue com
seu esforço individual se apenas 14% das
pessoas têm curso superior no brasil a
gente vai dizer que 86% das pessoas no
brasil não quiseram ou não se esforçaram
para ter curso superior a bom não vamos
exigir tanto afinal de contas com
superior não é nenhum grau obrigatório
escolar
vamos falar de alfabetização hoje no
brasil na atualidade nós temos 14
milhões de analfabetos é muita gente que
não tem força de vontade para aprender
ler e escrever né
nino é uma falta de falta de
determinação não é isso
só que fica mais grave ainda meus caros
quando a gente pensa quem são essas
pessoas que eles não são apenas números
setenta por cento das pessoas
analfabetas no brasil são negras
adivinhem a cor da pele de 70 por cento
daquelas pessoas que não têm curso
superior brasil
vamos falar então a diferença salarial
hoje uma pessoa branca ganha o dobro uma
média salarial o dobro do que uma pessoa
negra ganha de salário
na lógica simplista meritocrático a
gente vai poder dizer então que as
pessoas negras se esforçam se dedicam e
trabalham menos do que as pessoas
brancas
afinal de contas se o sucesso é
conseqüência das do seu da sua força de
vontade e as pessoas negras têm menos
sucesso do que as pessoas brancas
raciocínio lógico seria esse
as pessoas negras têm um menor nível de
escolaridade estão os piores postos de
trabalho têm os piores salários e lá no
outro lado fazem parte da maioria da
população carcerária
por isso é necessário antes da gente
reproduzir determinadas lógicas que são
comuns a gente refletir sobre os
fenômenos sociais refletir profundamente
sobre o significado de reproduzi los no
nosso cotidiano
a meritocracia
nada mais é do que um mito um mito que
foi criado logo depois da grande crise
de 1929 para poder dizer que se você
quiser sair da crise basta trabalhar
estudar e se dedicar
é na verdade foi uma 11 é no brasil é
uma versão do américa mg agora nada mais
oportuno o mundo e uma crise sem
precedentes ea resposta é estude se
dedique e trabalho além de ser oportuno
eu acho que é muito atual
por isso que nós somos bombardeados
cotidianamente pela história do que quem
quer consegue
o que é fundamental que as pessoas achem
que a desigualdade ela é um problema do
indivíduo
é fundamental que a gente acredite nisso
cotidianamente por isso que na escola
você escuta isso
por isso que nos programas de televisão
nós somos bombardeados por histórias de
pessoas que saíram da miséria e
trabalharam e se dedicaram à noite dia
como se isso fosse justo para poder
vencer o que não é dito é que o ser
humano é um ser social e com um ser
social
o ser humano está suscetível muito mais
as relações sociais é o contexto
histórico do que o seu próprio esforço
individual e isso é construído e
historicamente também não nos é dito que
essa sociedade cria oportunidades
diferentes a determinados grupos de
pessoas mais do que isso essa sociedade
cria graus de dificuldade diferentes a
determinados grupos de pessoas para
poder justificar a existência das
desigualdades
é esse o pano de fundo do racismo e do
machismo
são pessoas que têm grau de dificuldade
para ter acesso às oportunidades ainda
maiores que ocupam um lugar de
subalternidade na sociedade e por isso
se justifica a desigualdade como isso é
construído historicamente é importante a
gente entender que esse mesmo povo negro
que pode a gente poderia concluir pela
lógica meritocrática que é preguiçoso
que não se não trabalha que não se
dedica o suficiente esse mesmo povo
negro foi escravizado durante 300 anos
nesse país
foi esse mesmo povo que foi abandonado à
própria sorte
depois da abolição é preciso entender
que essa cidade aqui onde nós estamos
agora foi a última do mundo a abolir a
escravidão
meu disso campinas era um lugar que os
donos de escravos ameaçavam para poder
dizer que que eu mandar pra cá
ou seja a cidade foi construída em cima
do sangue negro assim como ao contrário
o povo europeu recebeu incentivos e
terras para poder se fixar no brasil
o que eu quero dizer com isso eu quero
dizer que um passado de diferentes
oportunidades gerou um presente com
profundas igualdades por isso não é
possível a gente falar de mérito em um
país que tem a quinta maior taxa de
feminicídios no mundo as mulheres nesse
país estão morrendo apenas porque são
mulheres
não é possível falar de mérito sem levar
em consideração que esse país é o
primeiro do mundo em assassinatos de
transexuais e travestis
não é possível falar de mérito sem
questionar a estrutura de privilégios
sobre qual este país foi construído não
é possível criar um futuro diferente sem
proporcionar oportunidades iguais
portanto antes de falar de meritocracia
é necessário a gente refletir porque
entre os 12 palestrantes do ted eu sou a
única negra
se nós somos mais de 50% da população
será que as pessoas negras de campinas
não poderiam falar sobre diversos outros
temas
é necessário refletir porque vocês que
são maioria que têm curso superior aqui
não tiveram professores universitários
negros pensa em sair na memória quem
teve
no máximo um que eu não tive nenhum
será que os professores negros não tem
capacidade nem vontade nem vocação para
serem professores universitários é
necessário a gente refletir porque a
trabalhadora doméstica é filha de uma
trabalhadora doméstica neta de uma outra
trabalhadora doméstica
essas mulheres estão aprisionadas em um
modelo de sociedade que torna
oportunidade é hereditário e é
importante a gente está cá ninguém tem
culpa por ter privilégio que nasceu com
eles mas você tem uma responsabilidade
maior
quando você repassa esses privilégios
como se fossem hereditários
quando você prolifera idéias e tornam
esses privilégios hereditários
então a mensagem eu quero deixar aqui é
que a gente não pode pensar num futuro
digno se a gente não pensar em equalizar
as oportunidades
a história de mulheres como eu que se
ultrapassar o racismo ultrapassar o
machismo e outras tantas outras questões
que perpassam a vida das mulheres negras
nesse país não deve servir para reforçar
o mito da meritocracia ao contrário tem
que servir para a gente pensar na
necessidade de proporcionar
oportunidades a um povo que está
historicamente excluído para poder
pensar um pouco mais eu vou parafrasear
angela davis é necessário lançar luz
sobre presente para que se possa ao
mesmo tempo e iluminar o futuro
obrigada
[Aplausos]